hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments seriously your fan
community is full of such caring and
open-minded people it's quite a
reflection of you as well as us as a
group oh well thank you very much oh
this is the first time I'm reading your
comments hasn't opened with a tick joke
or something highly inappropriate but
that does mean a lot especially
considering Saturday's charity
livestream which went incredibly well
like record-breaking number of people
were there so thank you everybody who
watched and just thank you everybody for
being open to the idea of being a close
knit community that's there for each
other I really am honored to know that
you guys watch me and even though I'm
just an idiot making a fool of himself
on the internet it really doesn't mean a
lot to know that you guys are willing to
take up these causes and willing to be
there for each other and that's what
really matters so thank you can someone
give me all the times with the penis
jokes Thanks well we're back in the
natural form good to know the priorities
of students are supposed to be all right
am I the only one who think mark would
make a great stand-up comedian well I
don't know about stand-up comedy just by
myself but I've been learning a lot
about improv comedy and I love improv
I've been a big fan of whose line for a
long time and it wasn't until recently
that I really started to learn like what
it is to do improv so I would love to
get to the point where I'm good enough
and I'm not nearly there yet but I'm
good enough that I could take some
friends of mine and we could actually go
to like a city run town a theatre maybe
do a charity event maybe just do it for
fun
and you know get you guys to come to the
theater and do an improv show for you
because I think that would be a lot more
rewarding than just us going around and
doing a Q&A across the country because
that seems a little asinine and
narcissistic so I would love to give you
guys a show for you know giving us the
honor if you guys coming to actually see
us that's amazing like the fact that you
guys would want to come to see us and we
go to conventions all the time so it'd
be nice to actually have something to
show for it but I don't know how it
happened maybe we could get some musical
acts together with that make a big show
out of it because we know on intersex
partying we know starbomb obviously so
it could be really cool but I have no
idea how that happened
how do you feel about Pizza onesies is
this literally pajamas that you can wear
that are made of pizza because that
sounds kind of awesome except for the
fact that you get Pizza grease all over
yourself and I don't think that would
turn out too well for your skin
it'd just be a walking pimple factory
everywhere unless their onesies that
actually have a designer pizza which
would show an unhealthy obsession with
pizza and probably there should be
something said about that so I feel
indifferent towards its theoretical
construct what is your favorite NSP song
oh speaking of ninja sex party ah oh man
I I kind of want to go with three
minutes of ecstasy I think is the name
of the title because the music video
Zach's
is totally on point the song is
hilarious and just it's just an overall
hilarious premise because they're all
their songs are amazing if you haven't
seen into sex parties videos there's a
link in the description what are you
even doing with your life go watch him
right now binge watch every music video
they're all fantastic so check them out
there but that's probably my favorite in
terms of humor but of course dinosaur
laser fight is has a special place in
everyone's heart because it's ego
raptures animation and Danny's ex bang
and ninja sex party and all the good
stuff so it's really cool
so check out any of them they're all
good yeah he has a weird life you have a
weird life
hey yeah I do have a weird life
considering I just did that thing that
you saw so anyway
moving up what do you do when you're not
recording literally absolutely nothing I
sit waiting patiently until I can record
again because my life is full of boredom
and disturbing paranoia it's in life of
endless suffering there's no God the
hurt my through what everyone else does
don't read don't load did I do that
right
I don't know mark do not crash dive into
the folding table don't do it you can't
tell me what to do Ryan help him I can't
write I can't swim get him get him
no I can't swim guys no oh no five oh
geez oh no mark
markiplier confirmed 4d club actually
yes I'm a proud member of the D Club and
if you have no idea what the D Club is
it's the club where your friends have
seen your penis that's literally the
long and short of it didn't mean to make
fun there but that's just the same
actually funny story me Aaron like
founded the D Club it's his baby
I shouldn't say that it's his idea
and so we were all at a Korean spot if
you don't know a Korean spa you get
naked in the Korean spa
so Barry Aaron and I we're in the
changing room we got naked we all met up
in like a circle we looked at each other
in the eye were like okay on three one
two okay we've seen each other's penises
we're good
good and the idea is if you're naked
with your friend it's awkward at first
but if you just hit it head-on
again bad choice of words here if you
just if you focus in on the problem
which is the dick can you focus in on it
acknowledge the awkwardness get it out
of the way everything it's just a penis
and that's all there is nothing to worry
about and then you go on with your debut
it sounds really bad the way I'm
explaining it but it sounds even worse
when Aaron explained it I don't know if
I can find a source but you guys can
point out in the comments woo off anyway
so I'm part of D Club I forgot one
episode that it was first talked on but
it's hilarious so anyway do a handstand
no oh God oh hey Mark I'm in college
right now and we was wondering do you
have any tips or tricks and how was your
experience like well as I've said before
college is a very interesting experience
it's far different from high school ever
will or could be if I could go back and
redo my college days it would have been
a bit more emphasis on my studies but
also more emphasis on going out and
meeting other people through various
clubs and activities because college is
a big melting pot people come to college
from all different walks of life and
there's different types of people and
yes there's the partygoers and the frat
bros and sorority sisters whatever
that's another side viewer you can
balance your party life in your social
life in their school life and academics
you can do all that balanced but also
take a wide variety of everything that
you can college is an experience that
you won't be able to relive again so
it's best to try to find what fits you
it's a good place to try a bunch of
things I'm not talking drugs and alcohol
that's not what I'm trying to say but
you can try different activities like
rock climbing swimming there's free
running there's like athletic clubs
there's intellectual clubs chess club's
video game clubs there's every sort of
Club you can imagine probably at your
college so go out there and find some
stuff if you find something that doesn't
work for
you there's always something else but
the more important thing is to go out
there and meet people because in the
real world as many people of seven it's
cliche at this point but it's not what
you know it's who you know and social
skills are at the heart of everything in
humanity and many of you may have social
anxiety you may have trouble going out
and meeting people but that's you know
that's a skill it's a skill to be
learned and the only way you're gonna
get better at it is going out there and
trying and I guarantee you if you feel
that you're shy or you have social
anxiety there are people that have more
social anxiety or are more shy that are
like just looking for someone akin to
them to try to talk to so that they can
understand each other's own awkwardness
so I'm not saying you guys are so
cripplingly awkward that you can't
interact with anybody but there's a
group of people that are like-minded and
you can agree with and you can find
interesting to learn about and hang out
with and there's also people that are
totally different from you that would be
equally rewarding to know the more
important thing is out of all this
rambling go out there try new things
learn everything you can because
learning is so important not just in
academics I'm not trying to be cliche
but learning every aspect of life social
skills societal skills everything needs
to be learned so that's my advice okay
so that's all the time I got for reading
your comments this time I spent a lot of
time doing with physical gags in this
one I'll try to plan this more ahead so
that I can do more stuff in the next
video but write your comments that you
want me to read say or do or literally
anything in the comments section below
it is hilarious reading the random crap
that you guys come up with and trying to
form it into something that I can do so
give me your heartfelt comments give me
your like Lowell random comments give me
any comment you want I'll try to figure
out a way to do it thank you everybody
so much for watching and thank you
everybody for joining me for the charity
livestream this past weekend we're going
to be doing them every month from now on
next one is tentatively March 19th but
that date can change cuz it's a little
far out
but thank you again everybody in total
including last time in this time we
raised two hundred and seventy three
thousand dollars for charity it's
probably more now so thanks again
everybody for joining me and as always I
will see you in the next video bye-bye